I don't believe profit is bad I believe
profit is good but the the the market
has to be with the the invisible hand of
the market has to be in a thick glove of
regulation and that glove has to be
appropriate it has to be flexible but it
nonetheless has to be in place and I
often think that by excluding
corporations all you do is encourage
them to undermine attack go around the
system I'm a believer it's better to
have them in the system have a
transparent and regulate them and have
other actors they're like nonprofits
that can disclose what's going on like
states that engage in regulation than to
have them outside and this is
particularly true in the world we live
in because there was a study that showed
that of the hundred most powerful
economic entities 51 are corporations 49
are states so people are living in a
dream world I'm not sure it was ever
true but it's certainly not true now
that states have just simply the power
to go out regulate and control
multinational corporations simply we're
going to have to accept that this is a
more complex world and that it how you
regulate and manage corporations is by
having multiple stakeholders and having
them at the table